every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalists podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists indeed we are this is
episode 30 of the podcast and it's gonna
be a bit of a unique episode usually for
those of you who are familiar with our
podcast you may want to go back through
the archives we answer a lot of
questions via voice mail when people
call in we also have lightning round
where answer questions from social media
and then we have various discussions and
many many digressions and tangents and
longer form discussions but this will
also be a bit of a discussion but in a
different vein for sure we're gonna talk
today about letting go and really
walking away whether that's for a
temporary period of time or for a longer
period of time so just a heads up this
is gonna be the last podcast you hear
from us at least for a little while but
we don't know how long we haven't set
aside a specific amount of time it may
be a couple weeks it may be much longer
than that we will figure that out and
we'll kind of talk about some reasons
why that's necessary but first Ryan I'd
like to read an essay that we can that I
wrote it's from our book essential which
is an essay collection of about 150
essays on simple living intentionality
there's actually 12 different chapters
span everything from decluttering and
minimalism to finances and passions and
mindfulness and a bunch of other
important areas of life and and this
essay is called the things we are
prepared to walk away from and I think
it'll be a good springboard for a
conversation about why we're gonna walk
away from this at least for a temporary
period of time
what are you prepared to walk away from
this often unasked question shapes one
of the most important principles in my
life we're all familiar with the age-old
theoretical situation in which our home
is burning and we must grab only the
things that are most important to us of
course most of us would not dash into
the inferno and reach for material
things first first we'd ensure the
safety of our loved ones and pets then
once they were safe we'd grab only the
irreplaceable things photo albums
computer hard drives family heirlooms
etc everything else would be lost in the
conflagration I tend to look at the
situation a tad differently though
taking the hypothetical a bit further
there's a scene in the movie heat in
which neo McCully Robert De Niro's
character says quote allow nothing in
your life that you cannot walk out on in
30 seconds flat
although my life isn't exactly like
Macaulay's in fact it's nothing like
Macaulay's he's the bad guy in the movie
I share his sentiment almost everything
I bring into my life material
possessions ideas habits and even
relationships I must be able to walk
away from at a moment's notice many of
you will disagree with me because this
ideology might sound crass or
insensitive but I'd like to posit that
it is actually the opposite our
preparedness to walk away is the
ultimate form of caring if I purchase
new possessions I need to make certain I
don't assign them too much meaning being
able to walk away means I won't ever get
too attached to my belongings and being
unattached to stuff makes our lives
tremendously flexible and filled with
opportunity if I take on a new idea or
habit I do so because it has the
potential to add value to my life new
ideas shape the future me same goes for
new habits over time my ideas change
improve and expand and my current habits
get replaced by new habits that continue
to help me grow our readiness to walk
away from
ideas or habits means we're willing to
grow we're willing to constantly pursue
a better version of ourselves if I bring
a new relationship into my world I know
that I must earn their love respect and
kindness I also expect that they too are
willing to walk away should I not
provide the support and understanding
they require this means we must work
both work hard to contribute to the
relationship we must communicate and
remain cognizant of each other's needs
and above all we must care these
fundaments love understanding caring
communication these fundaments build
trust which builds stronger
relationships in the long run it sounds
paradoxical but our willingness to walk
away actually strengthens our bond with
others and the opposite stance being
chained by obligation to a relationship
is disingenuous a false loyalty birth
from pious placation there are obvious
exceptions to this rule there are
certain things we cannot easily walk
away from a marriage a business
partnership a job that pays the rent a
passion the key is to have as few
exceptions as possible and naturally
even these exceptions aren't exceptions
for everyone
marriages often end as do businesses
people get laid off and passions change
over time even though we might not be
able to walk away from these things in
quote 30 seconds flat we can't all
tamale walk away when these situations
no longer add value to our lives are
worse when they drain value from our
lives everything I allow into my life
enters it deliberately if my home was a
flame there's nothing I own that can't
be replaced
all my photos are scanned all my
important files are backed up and all my
stuff has no real meaning similarly I'm
prepared to walk away from nearly
anything even our website
teaching my writing class or even
writing itself if need be doing so
safeguards my continued growth and
improves my relationships with others
both of which contribute to a fulfilling
life a life of meaning it was CS Lewis
who fifty years ago
eloquently said don't let your happiness
depend on something you may lose in
today's material world a world of fear
fueled clinging his words seem more
apropos than ever are you breaking up
with me no actually that that's actually
the cool thing is is I would and sure
and that that's really what that essay
is about there is a willingness to walk
away from anyone anything strengthens a
relationship because I know that if I
stopped adding value to your life or you
stop adding value to mine or the
dynamics change we could work on that
together as the phrase I use in there
was was pious placation and I can
remember and this is not to disparage my
former spouse who was a wonderful person
but in my marriage there was much of
that like we were there just because we
were there and I think it was it was you
know Mark Twain who said something like
wherever you go there you are or
something and I I kind of feel that
that's that's what happens is we we sort
of go with the flow for a designated
period of time and that sounds great
like really chill you know spiritual
yeah man I'm just gonna go with the flow
well the problem is eventually you end
up at the rapids and and then you're in
for a world of hurt but if you're if
you're paddling against the flow you're
doing so deliberately
and so you know in which direction you
are traveling and and I think it's
important to to be cognizant of i but
you can go with the flow as long as you
know where it's taking you right and and
then when it's no longer taking you
where you need to go then didn't be
aware of that and be willing to stop
what you're doing for a while and you so
to continue that metaphor maybe it's
about like getting
you know I was floating the river on my
birthday a few weeks ago here in
Missoula and when I was folding the
river there were these little like
little tiny sand beaches you know about
them because you're on the river all the
time
and you can stop whenever you want and
well not when everyone but just about
whenever you want sometimes it's okay to
just kind of stop and and reorient
yourself with what's going on and and so
I wanted to talk with you today about
some of this so Ryan you know about this
really well I'm I'm really good at
working hard yeah I am what some people
might refer to as a workaholic I think
part of that has to do with just
conditioning if I condition myself to to
see achievement and status in in the
corporate world and you get a lot of
accolades for that a lot of rewards what
we've often called you know food pellets
from the universe right it's like you're
that that rat that's running on the or
the hamster on the wheel basically and
and and or even you that I think I love
was Pavlov or someone else the the
scientist did the experiments where the
rats would go up and hit the lever to
get the food right and and we're trying
to do that and and the problem is the
food that I was getting in that
corporate world were these weird you
know
here's your President's Club trophy and
I remember when I was going through my
whole decluttering and that was a hard
thing for me to get rid of was I had
these you know a shelf of trophies and
awards and it's like but these don't
define who I am as a person and but I
got there because of working 80 hours a
week constantly and I forsook a lot of
other areas of my life and the thing
that minimalism has allowed me to do is
it allowed me to regain a lot of balance
in my life so in our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life we we
talked about the five higher-order
values health relationships passion
growth and contribution and whenever on
the road you talked a lot about this
Ryan about how you're only as strong as
the weakest link there and so you can
have
four of those that are just going great
your relationships are awesome and you
feel like you're pursuing your passion
for me that's writing and you're doing
it every day and it's great and it's
going really well most of the time even
though they're their speed bumps or
whatever sometimes but you're pursuing
your passion you feel like you're
growing and all these new awesome ways
and you feel like you're contributing to
the world around you but if you don't
have your health then then you don't
have anything right you know the guy
who's on his deathbed but has all these
other things is still on his deathbed
right or the richest man in the
graveyard is still dead and so for the
last couple years that's been sort of my
situation and I've been less acutely
aware of it and I've just pushed through
a lot of a lot of things so Ryan and I
went on tour and in 2014 and it was a
crazy whirlwind tour a hundred and
nineteen events hundred cities eight
countries over the course of ten months
I mean every few days we were in a new
city
we were on the road driving like crazy
it really screwed up my back but also
gave me significant adrenal fatigue
I remember the the December that year
after everything was over just coming
back and being like and shocked and I
talked about this as a metaphor in a
previous podcast uh the LA podcast which
was our last podcast that we posted it
kind of felt like those runaway trucks
when they finally stop and you just feel
like you sit there shaking for a while
like that was a traumatic experience our
our tour manager called a PTSD
post-traumatic tourists or you know post
or stress syndrome and and well
obviously it's it's I don't mean
anything toward people who have true
PTSD it is a form of that they're
actually fairly similar we before we
even had the term PTSD we had the term
shell-shocked and we wouldn't just apply
that term to people who were
shell-shocked for more there were other
experiences stock market crashes but but
just other extreme experiences in life
and so for me what I've learned a very
recent
our body doesn't differentiate between
good stress and bad stress stress is
stress so there's happy stress being on
tour for a year was amazing experience I
mean oh my god it transformed me I still
have so many great memories like I have
so many things I go back to constantly
when we were over in the UK or Australia
or driving through Mississippi and and
Oregon and everywhere else in this
country we were able to touch so many
people and have this profound effect on
a lot of people and get this sort of
kinesthetic learning of hugging tens of
thousands of people and it was an
experience that definitely transformed
my life but afterward I felt drained and
for the most of 2015 which was last year
I was dealing with issues from them my
back got way worse because of all the
sitting and travel that we had done so I
have a really bad back for those of you
who have listened to past episodes but
the weird thing is my health is both
better than ever but in some ways worse
than ever because of this so when you
become acutely aware of what's going on
in your health like my diet is better
than it's ever been my diet is better
than ninety nine point some percent of
the population and in this country for
sure my exercise routine is better than
the vast majority of of Americans and my
overall awareness of health is way up
there but but I also am going through a
lot in terms of adrenal fatigue right
now so we've gone on a couple tours
we've done a bunch of things since that
that 2014 tour we did the word tasting
tour last year and we've done a lot of
work with a bunch of different charities
and trying to contribute to the world
and give give give give give we started
this podcast with you know it's
advertisement free so it's not like
we're we're more you know banking on
this podcast that's not all we do it we
do it because it's contributing to the
world in the way it's another medium
through which we can communicate just
like our books have been and
and our blog has been which is free
there's been a bunch of different ways
for us to communicate with the world
this podcast has been one of those ways
and we're very fortunate enough that
people are listening to it but but at
the same time I've experienced this this
fatigue that as has gotten me to a point
where I am I'm aware that I need to go
all the way in and truly address it not
just address symptoms and but but go
into you know what what the problem is
and I'm working with with three or four
doctors right now to to try to figure
out this adrenal fatigue and try to
figure out you know my hormone levels
and your cortisol and testosterone and
all of these different things also I
have extreme sensitivities and allergies
that have popped up over the last few
years and gotten much worse and my micro
gut biome is way out of whack because of
likely because of some antibiotics I
took through my in my late 20s and early
30s and developed a ton of allergies
because of that and so again becoming
very aware of these things but at the
same time trying to figure out how do I
get to the other side to where where I'm
not just functionally healthy but I'm
I'm the best version of myself and so
that's why I want to put this on pause
for a bit this podcast because you and I
have talked about this I don't know if
it was on air necessarily but we're
definitely better together when we do
this - when we do this podcast together
it's you and I have both recorded one
individual episode of peace and I
remember feeling good about the one I
recorded when I when I sat down with
Sean our our talented and fearless
producer here we you were out of town
and I just sat down and recorded a
podcast I felt great about and I listen
back to it I'm like man that was really
missing a lot and it's because it was
missing it was missing you and vice
versa like I I felt I felt the same
thing about yours too like your attitude
yours was it was missing the dynamic you
know it's not the minimalist were the
minimalists and
and there are many ways that we help
complement and also compensate for each
other our personalities are vastly
different in fact I was reading some
stuff about personalities recently Ryan
so this is probably a good thing to talk
about like I said my personnel I'm an
INTJ which means and I'm a very high I a
low in and by the high tea high J as
well and you're an ENFP and you're
actually high in so we're almost exact
opposites in terms of personnel and in
terms of personality but but when I when
I look at that personality that
personality lends itself to just doing
heavy work being analytical and sitting
down and and drudging through the
drudgery get getting the problem solved
and to the point where I will forsake
other things if I don't force myself to
it'd be easy for me to sit down for 14
hours a day and just write for the rest
of my life well it would be a pretty
attenuated life if I did that though
because I wouldn't be focused on health
or relationships and I'd end up like
Howard Hughes and and none of us want
then so being focused on the balance of
life is really important and you have a
far more balanced life than I do because
of that because your personality also
lends itself to being being more
balanced but I also think that you you
focus more on that than I do
so what I wanted to do we have a couple
obligations that they're coming up in
the next few weeks
Ryan unite we have a TEDx talk that
we're doing in Fargo on well it's it's
toward the end of July but we're also
doing while we're there we're gonna do a
tour stop in Fargo because we already
have a plan we've already have people
committed to it we're gonna screen our
film which is called minimalism there
before it comes out online so we went on
tour last one we're not going to go on
another tour for a while but while we're
in Fargo we're gonna have a single tour
stop there and we're also going to
record hopefully a live version of this
podcast we also have some some other
podcasts banked we've recorded other
podcasts we haven't published who's also
recorded some live podcasts that we that
we
not published but will hopefully do one
in Fargo on I believe it is July 19th I
think there's still some tickets
available to that you can find those at
the minimalists comm slash tour I
believe and and then in August I think
it's August 10th I made a mistake on our
last podcast I said August 11th but it's
August 10th we were gonna be in Orlando
and that was just because we wanted to
find a way to help the victims of this
terrible terrorist shooting that
happened and well obviously we can't
help in every scenario with our limited
resources it was one thing we wanted to
do to try to try to give back so we'll
be down in Orlando a hundred percent of
all the the profits from that go to the
Victims Fund that we've connected with
to to help out the the still-living
victims I mean they're there dozens of
people who were injured in that who are
still alive that we we want to be able
to help out in some way and so you can
help with that too so that's August 10th
2016 in the middle of that our
documentary comes out online which it'll
be out you just go to minimalism film
calm you can pre-order it get a bunch of
bonus content there all the folks at
spire media and Dave our director have
been hard working at the content there
I've actually been really happy with
that Ryan I don't know if yeah it looks
great
I mean Leo we what I liked about is it's
like a less fleshed-out version of our
of our documentary yeah it just allows
people to dive deeper in with with
people's interviews and personalities
and all the folks in our documentary you
just get to know them a little bit
better personality a lot better really
yeah well the personnel he's a great
worker I was watching the the bonus
interview with Leo which I think was
half hour so so Leo about a father of
six husband lives in California runs a
website called Zen habits dotnet he was
one of the inspirations for us to get
into minimalism but also to start to
start a website and and and inspire
other people through our own stories and
in the interview he's just so honest I
mean I think Leo is the coolest guy I've
ever met
I was talking to him on skype last week
and our two weeks ago rather and and
yeah but in this bonus footage that I
was reviewing that that um Matt put
together our director I asked him a
question about something I remember what
the question was because the answer was
so profound it didn't matter what the
question was he said I don't have a good
answer to that question now when you
have an answer like that and then he
starts sort of rambling at first and
going on tangents but that's that to me
while you can't fit that into a lean 79
minute narrative you know a documentary
that that we're trying to boil down to
its essence those beautiful excerpts
like that that didn't make the film
really do bring out the personality and
those people and these people are gurus
they don't have all the answers you and
I don't have all the answers nor do we
pretend to we have a recipe that's
worked well for us but even that recipe
will roll into tweak we're willing to
change and so that essay that I read at
the opening it's about walking away and
I wrote it but I wrote about it
initially and with the intent of being
willing to walk away from anything you
know you and I have both been married
before we walked away from from those
whether it was our our own choice or not
now we we had to move on and we had to
finally decide to move on I walked away
from a career you were laid off from a
job and we have to walk away from those
things or you can sit and sulk and
perpetuity and then not walk away but
doesn't really really do you any good
but what I want to talk to you about
today a little bit Ryan is sometimes
it's okay to walk away temporarily you
know to find that that little beach on
the side of the the side of the river
and say okay I need to get get off of
here for a minute so that I can focus on
something else so that I saw that I can
regroup so yes we'll come back and do
this podcast maybe we'll do it with some
irregularity well hey Ryan would you
like to sit down this month and do a
podcast or something like that maybe
we'll come back and do seven a week I
have no idea I doubt that will happen
but but the thing I'm focused on first
is making sure the trajectory of my
health is as radically improved I'd
spent the last 10 days in California
with my partner Becca and it was an
amazing experience because I basically
didn't check email I checked it a few
times while I was there I didn't focus
on anything overly strenuous or even
anything too creative and even my back
exercises I laid back on a bit because
I've been doing three to four hours of
back exercise every day because of my my
spongeable spondylolysis and
spondylolisthesis and which means i've a
pinched nerve and my vertebrae is broken
anyway i've even backed off of that a
little bit because I found out stressing
myself out with that and I'm still doing
a number of exercise to help with that
but I realized I needed to back off and
figure out what are the fundamentals
that work and I removed myself also also
from some of the the chemicals chemicals
I have a chemical sensitivity to certain
things I've noticed that with the
apartment I've I've moved to last year
that that I have some sensitivities to
the the floor sealant and and
potentially to some of the paint and and
and so it's it's caused some cognitive
issues in terms of having brain fog but
also some allergic reactions and an
immune deficiencies my autoimmune system
has been compromised for sure but when I
when I was away for those 10 days Ryan I
just got back yesterday I I felt better
than I felt in a year and a half and it
was amazing seeing this this difference
oh my god I'm alive again like you don't
know it until you like walk away from it
right so you don't know you're in the
matrix to these stuff away from it or
whatever come up with a better analogy
I'm sure there is one but you it's the
the David Foster Wallace thing right to
fish or two young fish or swimming in
water and all right an older fish swims
Biden said morning boys how's the water
and and the one fish looks at the other
fish and he says what the hell is water
and it's because that's all you're used
to when you're surrounded by it but if
you get away from it for a while you
come back to it and you realize oh this
is water
and and so I've become very aware of
what's going on in my life and and I
want to be able to contribute as much as
I can and that's why I would recommend
the people if you if you enjoy this
podcast there are as a whole archive
there's 30 episodes now over 30 hours of
us having discussions on a bunch of
different topics each episode generally
has a a topic that will digress on but
but it has a theme for the most part so
go back and listen to those check out
the documentary you can check out our
blog which has close to a thousand
essays on and now all the archives that
are there and you you also can check out
you know our books or anything else
we've done
yeah the TED talk that we've done in the
past the one we have coming up but
besides the the few commitments I just
mentioned the documentary coming out
Fargo and Orlando I'm pulling everything
off of my plate and you know we even
talked about pulling those off the play
we pulled a bunch of other things and
I've said no to to dozens of interviews
at this point and something because I
don't want to do those things I would
love to do those things but I don't have
the full capacity to do those things
right now and so Ryan you've been kind
to take over a lot of that stuff and and
the planning for our TEDx talk and also
a lot of the interviews and stuff that's
been going on so I mean at this point I
would love to talk to you about about
what walking away means and then what
walking back to this means for us for
the minimalists because to me this isn't
a negative thing this is this is a
positive thing being able to walk away
so I can walk back to it with full
intention yeah well I mean going back to
the you know right at the beginning of
the podcast where you were talking about
you know I was joking around like oh are
you are you breaking up with me and
you're like oh I never walk away from
you but you're like but no seriously I I
am totally prepared to walk away from
you sure um no I think that it is
important to have that attitude towards
towards anything in my life like it's
I'm not gonna name like the family
member because I don't want to like call
anyone out on the podcast but I had a
family member who was like they were
just being really egregious and and I
just looked at them and I was like you
know my friends they don't treat me this
way and my family member was like
friends
we're family we're more than friends and
like you know started like kind of
coming at me like that and I'm like
right I agree with you family is more
than friends and my friends don't treat
me this way
yes so isn't it even more important that
you and I get along rather than you know
create this this this hostility between
us and that is where I think
relationships or activities like this
podcast or writing or whatever it may be
anything on our lives that we have an
obligation towards it's really oh it's
just really dangerous if we're if we're
doing things strictly out of obligation
now we are obliged to what like follow
you know the the speeding laws we're
obliged to you know treat treat one
another with respect I mean there are
things that we are obligated to do don't
get me wrong but but only only in
certain contexts right like if you own
you know your own ranch in Montana you
can drive 140 miles an hour on your own
private driveway yeah but we we we've
essentially signed a social contract to
say if we're gonna drive on the public
roads we're gonna do you know we're
going to do that so they're even like I
said in the essay there are even
exceptions to the things we think there
aren't exceptions for so I guess maybe a
better way said is the things that we're
blood to in life you know I think that
anytime we find ourselves just feeling a
severe amount of disdain towards
something that we're obligated to we
really need to take a look at that and
ask ourselves are we actually obligated
to this who why are we obligated to this
so in in in your case Josh you know
we're obligated to these podcasts I'm
sure we started doing this is something
we're committed to this is something
that we want to put out on a regular
basis just like any of our other works
we're very consistant we have really
high quality with it so
we are you know for all intents and
purposes obligated to this podcast yeah
and and this is something that you're
looking at and saying man I'm obligated
to this podcast but I'm only obligated
because I am making myself feel
obligated to it yeah yeah well it really
you know what stood out to me man was
you and I we were with Rob Bell last
year we went to one of his two-day
events and he said something to you that
has just stuck with me ever since that
you were asking about the pressure you
feel from certain obligations basically
that's not the word he used but he just
looked at you and and in a very parable
kind of way just said you were looking
for this long profound you know
exploratory explanation that for him do
you know give you a dissertation for
five minutes because you wanted the
how-to steps and he just looked at you
and said everything you're carrying you
picked up and I was like oh I mean the I
felt that like down low my bone marrow
when he said that and it's so true like
but but here's here's the the the
obverse of that Ryan is someone like my
best times the some of the things I
enjoy most are when we were recording
this podcast and it's going really well
I think of the last two in studio
podcast who recorded we did the passion
one and the debt podcast two of my
favorites and I remember walking out of
both of those feeling euphoric it was
going so well the same euphoria that I
get from writing and I generally don't
get that from anything else besides sex
and and so so you have the this creative
experience when it's going really well
it's awesome it doesn't go well most of
the time most people don't notice when
we record a podcast it doesn't always
get published because we'll get to the
end of it and we're like I just want to
feel on that or well listen to it a day
or so later and say oh
and like that I didn't like that
sometimes would be in middle podcast
I'll just look up at you and say I'm
incoherent right now we have to stop and
and we'll stop recording it and and so
that part is really stressful to me so
so I think that you have to have that
that stress to get to those creative
high points that euphoria I don't think
you can have one without the other it
can't be all great creative flow state
all the time the problem with that for
me right now is that stress adds to my
my fatigue and as I said earlier the
body which I've learned very recently
from some of the doctors and
nutritionists and different people I'm
working with with I'm doing blood tests
and stool tests and urine tests and all
these gross things that that I won't go
into detail on but I've learned that the
body it does not differentiate you can
be an really crazy negative high stress
situations back when we were working a
retail Ryan and we were working at Black
Friday it was stressful and not the good
kind of stress you didn't look forward
to Black Friday but you do look forward
to going on tour and getting out there
and and spreading and sharing this
message we really believe in but your
body your adrenals your your hormones
your health doesn't differentiate
between the two and I you know it took
me 35 years to sort of realize that and
now I'm at a point where I'm I I want to
keep doing this podcast it's absolutely
something that I plan on coming back to
because I feel like we're finally
starting to get somewhere with it and it
feels good to be able to to put this out
there in the world and and have these
conversations with you and answer
people's questions as well I think we we
definitely don't have all the answers
but we have 12 really good answers that
we can keep giving over and over and try
to reword them appropriately but but in
all seriousness like I feel good about
some of the conversations we have
and I mean you and I have always had
some great conversations and I feel like
the podcast is just an extension of that
being able to sit down and turn some
microphones on and have these
conversations that other people can find
benefit from as well yeah even though
something like this does add a
tremendous amount of value and going
back to what I was saying about you know
that family member that family member
that relationship with that particular
family member it adds a lot of value
like I love that family member to death
I would do anything for that family
member except continue to associate with
them out of obligation even when that
relationship was literally well not
literally but you I guess figuratively
tearing me down yeah well that's the the
like I said in the essay that kind of
obligation is disingenuous right yeah
exactly
I think we're pretending were we are
pretending to to keep going status quo
everything is okay when it's not
necessarily okay and that's what I
wanted to bring up today yeah I mean
when we are we have relationships in our
lives or if we have activities in our
lives that are ultimately tearing us
down those are things that we should be
prepared to walk away from in in Mille
going back to we should be referred to
walking away from everything I mean I
even Mariah like if Mariah started I
don't know I'm not gonna like throw out
some crazy example but there are some
things I'm sure she could do where I
would be like what are you doing yeah
she started beating you sure right she
started beating me there's a point where
I'm gonna be like okay this is a habit
that now you're taking like I have to
walk away from this because it's tearing
me now no matter how much I love you
I've got to walk away from this and and
it is okay and you know to your to your
point earlier you were talking about
walking back and maybe she goes and like
you know get some counseling and like
she gets better and then I choose to
walk back that's perfectly okay in this
situation we're talking about your
health
and and in what I love about like kind
of how we're approaching this is it's
not a you know
we're not putting a time limit on it
it's not like okay well we're gonna just
kind of lay back lay off the podcast for
a little bit two months because that's
when Josh will have all the tests and
get his tests back and who knows maybe
you will be fixed in two months yeah but
that's not a guarantee and we walking
away from this obligation we don't want
to as we're walking away still keep it
as an obligation because if we were
sitting to sit here and tell our
audience like hey we'll be back in two
months or we'll be back in two weeks or
whatever the time for him is and well
now we're obligated to come back yeah
yeah and so I what I also like about
that is without that obligation I may
call you up one day a week or two from
now and say hey man I really wanted to
record a podcast about this and we're
not obligated to do it now like we don't
have to come in here every Monday or
whenever we do it
and say okay we're ready to record our
podcast here's our voicemails here's
whatever I do again I enjoy that format
and in a regular course of Health I
wouldn't have a problem doing and I
would prefer to do it that way it's
regimented and it's organized that fits
my personality really well but but being
untethered from from that obligation
allows us the opportunity to sort of do
what Sam Harris does with his podcast
which is one of my favorite podcast I
donate money to it frequently because he
he also he actually stopped doing
advertisements I wonder who he got that
idea from very recently he stopped doing
advertisements and and now you can just
like donate to his podcast like you
candid ours but just go to the
minimalists calm slash donate is I was
listening to his podcast this morning
when I was doing my back exercises and
and he just puts out a podcast whenever
he feels inclined to do so he put out
two this week sometimes they'll go a
month without putting one out and I'm
close to two months without putting a
podcast out and then he'll put out two
in a week and it's just because
sometimes they're topical is that I want
to talk about about you know the the
presidential election and
so the Orlando attacks or whatever or I
want to have this scientists on and talk
about free will and it's whenever he
feels inclined to do so but it doesn't
have that that obligatory I have to
publish something every Tuesday
otherwise you know the people who are
expecting it it's like I guess that word
expectation is letting go of
expectations in a way and not allowing
others expectations to shape or frame
what you're trying to create as well and
again we've everything that we picked up
everything they were carrying we picked
up also all the expectations we that are
out there we we've created them to too
many extent or people have manufactured
them on their own and and while we've
published basically a podcast every week
for the last thirty or so weeks we don't
have to continue to fill that same
expectation we can do more we could do
less we could do none it's up to us to
to continue to decide what is right for
us and ideally that'll change over time
and now that change will allow us to to
grow over time yeah so you know if
there's anyone out there right now who
has an obligation that they just
absolutely lows you know I would I would
challenge you to look at that obligation
and ask yourself why am i obligated to
this now someone listening this is gonna
say well I'm obligated because my boss
wants me to do it and I got a you know I
got to do this for him and if I don't
then I get fired and then I can't pay my
bills and you know what someone in that
situation then yeah I would say that you
are obligated to to your boss but you
know you're not necessarily obligated to
your to your job meaning that you could
certainly explore other opportunities
and other areas so you don't have to
continue living up to someone else's
obligations I mean even if even if let's
say and I'm just throwing out an example
here you know I mean that's this isn't
gonna be out for everyone but you know
like I'm looking at my situation where I
was in the corporate world where
in 60 70 80 hours a week and my whole
thing was like I'm gonna pay off all my
debt I'm gonna become debt free and then
I'm gonna be a barista and I'm gonna
like have an apartment cousin Ohio
that's really cheap because in Ohio you
can get an apartment for you know four I
think I was paying for 25 a month sure
it was it was a one-and-a-half bathroom
two bedroom so I heard two baths one and
a half bedroom two bathrooms um for like
425 or for other way around 450 month no
it really was one and a half bedrooms
and two bathrooms I guess it would be
one and a half bathrooms because yeah
the one bathroom downstairs didn't have
a shower in it so it was one of the half
bathrooms one and a half bedrooms it was
like an office like I couldn't fit a
queen bed in there it would be like a
twin bed and there'd be like a kid's
bedroom exactly so anyway
regardless what I'm saying is is that
someone who is in that situation right
now where they they are feeling
obligated to something that you know if
they walk away from them they can't pay
their bills well you know try to find
something else even if it pays a little
bit less like like so I started off with
a question like okay I don't think I
cause I didn't have a degree at the time
I was like you know I didn't think I
could leave and make you know well into
six figures somewhere else just starting
out so my question wasn't lay or the
solution wasn't well I can't you know
make more than six figures anywhere else
so I'm gonna stay here and continue to
hate this my solution was all right well
how can I live off of less how can i how
can i free up some of this time how can
i reclaim some of my time and and still
live a meaningful life giving up one
resource for another and right yeah
exactly exactly so so I mean there are
there are ways to to get away from these
obligations that are that are just
tearing us down on a daily basis and
it's sometimes it's it would take
sometimes it takes a unique idea and
quite often every time it will it will
take a lot of bravery to walk away from
something yeah it's I was listening to
sam harris talked about bravery recently
Ryan and he was talking about how
bravery is sort of the one thing that
can't be faked because even if you fake
it you are by definition being brave so
go ahead and fake that bravery because
that that's all the bravery or courage
or whatever you want to call it takes is
that willingness to actually make that
change right in the face of adversity so
even if you're faking courage it's
actually courageous to do so and and so
there is not a distinction and and yes I
agree with Ryan you may not be able to
walk away from everything and quote 30
seconds flat well that's the ideal
vision and that's a great place to to
get to or actually not even to get to a
great place to which to aspire is to be
able to walk away from from anything in
30 seconds flat it's still the
willingness to walk away from something
if it's no longer in line with your
values which for me one of my values is
health and like I said early on my
health is both better and worse than
it's ever been
well it's not like it's not the podcast
this podcast isn't aligned with your
values as much as the value that this
podcast adds it does not it does not
compensate for what it's doing
to your health and it's not just this
podcast I mean it's it's all of the work
that that we have taken on over the last
two or three years sure so yeah I mean
it's even though you may be doing one
thing so there's you know maybe someone
out there who is you know busting their
their their chops to are busting their
humps but I don't know what the idiom is
but they're working really hard every
week maybe they're like donating time
every single evening to an orphanage or
something but at the end of the day like
they're coming home they're very very
tired they're not getting enough sleep
for work the next day they're not paying
attention to their to their family who
really needs their attention even though
they're doing this amazing thing it's
taking away from a lot of other areas in
their life and and as again you said
earlier the beginning of the podcast
like our values are well the first one
we mentioned is health yes and there's a
reason that that's fur
right and and and so you know looking at
what we're doing now it's great there
are millions of people who are who are
getting a benefit from this I mean we're
adding value like I never even imagined
we would be anything like we you know
like I never would imagine we be adding
value before and and that's great but
your health is suffering and that has to
be priority number one right now right
because if I don't have anything to give
I can't continue to give and that's when
I when I say doesn't align with values I
mean in the present moment because it
doesn't allow me to to focus on on my
health and and that's that has to come
first right now so that I can serve all
other areas of my life because you know
I've become depleted and I haven't
intentionally forsook my health in fact
I've been very focused on my health my
diet is phenomenal my exercise routine
is great
I you know I weigh 80 pounds less than I
did at my my pinnacle of you know I
weigh 240 pounds on one thought at one
point and and I was just unhealthy I ate
I crap I didn't exercise it was very
sedentary and I don't have that same
lifestyle now but but now as I'm getting
older and it's weird to say that but you
know I'm 35 now so I'm not an old man
but by any stretch but I I've become
more aware of the sensitivities and and
the subtle changes that I need to be
more focused on and so yes I'm going to
focus on that for a period of time and
and ideally in perpetuity but once I
have it turned around then it's easier
to focus on it's like anything else in
life well once you've built a habit and
fixed something it's easier to to
maintain but right now I'm I am in the
fixing process but I think you brought
up a really good point just a moment ago
it's not just the podcast it's
everything else that we have done and
yeah this is one thing we're taking off
our plates right and so you can focus on
your health and many other things that
we're also taking off of our plates
within last year so jessica has been
helping us with social media which has
been great you know you and I are still
pretty active on social media Twitter
and Facebook and we still respond to
people's comments it still
but she helps engage people in a
different way she finds great articles
to post onto our Facebook page and gets
people involved there she gets people
involved a minimalist org which we have
those free local meetup groups and so
she's been able to help take that off of
off of our play Shawn does a lot of the
operational stuff in addition to our
podcast that helps the the minimalists
be this well-oiled machine that helps a
lot of people in a bunch of different
ways and so what we're doing now is
we're looking at okay one of the things
that we can take off of our plate and to
use an overused term get back to basics
and for me the basics right now or just
health and then how do i layer and the
other stuff well once once that that is
fixed we come back and say okay what
does the podcast look like at this point
what is what other creative projects you
and I have talked about this on the
podcast before and certainly in our
events but we tend to focus on one big
project a year so this year it's getting
the documentary out into the world the
theatrical release was I mean oh my god
how much work that we put into that
theatrical release we spent the last
almost year really but especially the
last six months heavily focused and
working with the team over a gather and
and everyone there and a ton of theaters
and and movie captains and all of these
different people to to get this film out
to to the masses out into theaters and
that was a lot of work and of course
writing for the blog and of course
writing for me which is a daily habit of
mine that I want to continue to focus on
but I'm also setting that aside so we're
setting a lot of things aside so that we
can come back and deliberately add those
things back in one by one I think of on
our last on the on the debt podcast we
talked very briefly about the needwant
like list Shawn I think put that in the
notes the minimalist calm slash wound
but when Ryan and I were both you're
going through the process of how can I
live off of less how can i untether
myself from this opulent lifestyle which
didn't even seem opulent at the time it
was just like you add one thing and one
bill and one knew this one knew that and
all of a sudden you're at this place
ten years later and you're like oh my
goodness how did I get here well it was
one brick at a time and and so what we
did is we came up with this need want
like list which basically means there
are certain things we have in our life
that we like and I got rid of all of
those likes there were costing me money
at the time but this could be applicable
of things that don't cost money as well
yeah things like satellite radio that
were cost me money but we're all your
likes in your life month to I got rid of
all of all of my once so things that
added value to my life but like the like
this podcast would be an example of
something certainly has died in my life
I enjoy it writing adds immense value to
my life really want to do it you really
want to do it but it's not an absolute
need not an absolute must and then the
needs was a third category and I even
realized that I could reduce my needs by
50% I moved into a smaller apartment I
cut back on gas and food and you know
all these other areas in a very
deliberate way you know sort of using
those first two were using a chainsaw
and then I got down to the scalpel level
with with the needs list and the cool
thing about that is once you get down to
what you absolutely need what is
essential then you can add those once
back in but you do so very deliberately
and you realize those things that you
once wanted aren't the things that you
still want going forward because the
past does not equal the future and and
so I was able to bring those once back
into my life slowly but in a deliberate
way asking that question does this add
value to my life and in many cases the
answer was yes but in a different way a
good example would be the cell phone
when I got rid of my cell phone for a
couple months I brought it back into my
life but I used it differently
no more Facebook and no more email on my
phone but I use it to send text messages
or or for GPS and music and podcast and
and I think the same can be true for
this podcast is it's evolved a lot over
the last 30 episodes but it will evolve
even more going forward however we
choose to bring it back in
into our lives you know and it could be
that we we do more conversations just
like this or it could mean that we do it
more infrequently it can mean a whole
host of things the question is what adds
lie to our lives allows us to contribute
to other people as well and and if we're
if we're asking those questions being
deliberate or being a rigorous with
those questions we're gonna get a lot
more benefit in a long run than just
being tied to any project through
perpetual obligation I think that's
probably a good place to to wrap up wrap
it up yeah well we'll be back eventually
and like I said we'll probably we have
some we have some good podcasts recorded
that we could probably pepper into the
feed occasionally we may or may not do
that soon be on the lookout for our
documentary you can find that over at
minimalism film.com
and i think we have some responses as
well Shawn from some of our our our past
episodes we asked people to call in and
and if you have a response even to this
episode you're welcome to call in as
well it's four oh six two one nine seven
eight three nine let's listen to some of
our listeners and feedback from passion
and debt or whatever other podcasts we
have we have some feedback on hi guys
this is Kristin from Charleston South
Carolina I just wanted to say that it
was never my intention for my family to
follow what I do and you know to try to
become them with themselves and I just
wanted to do it for myself
but when they saw the positive effects
that had on my life and they just really
wanted that for themselves and the
positive energy that was coming from me
and how it had changed my life made them
want to change and my husband is
completely on board now I never even had
to tell him to do it even though my mom
and my dad who you know I don't even
live with them have been hearing about
my story and they are wanting to do it
too
so a lot of your followers asked
questions about how to get their family
members do you minimize like them and I
really think it's all about living by
example and you can never tell anyone to
make changes such as you can't tell
someone that they need to lose weight
and they have to want to be able to do
it for themselves
hello this dispenser calling from the
Bronx I wanted to leave a comment you
guys about setting up triggers I know
you would talk about setting up triggers
in your in a previous podcast where you
talked about it major like right Josh
has is walking down the stairs seeing
the pull-up bar
one thing that I've tried to do more and
more in my life is remove the amount of
time that I spend wasting time on my
cell phone where I would just kind of
check something and it's not productive
time spent is mostly distracted time
spent and so one thing I've done is I
went any any time I reach for my cell
phone I try and set up another kind of
trigger so for example a lot of times I
will boil water to make tea or coffee in
the morning and instead of reaching for
my cell phone there I'll think oh I'm
here to have this moment and I'll do
some sort of really simple exercise that
I can do which gets it and you know
improves my health makes me feel like
I'm being more productive and it's just
a time waster so for example instead of
checking my cell phone I'll just start
doing squats until the teas that
seawater is ready and I try and set up
these little triggers everywhere in my
life where I would normally be sitting
checking my cell phone and instead try
and do some sort of physical activity
and obviously in public that can look a
little strange if you like you know
waiting for the subway train and also
I'm you're doing squats so you might not
want to do that but setting up these
little triggers and figuring out what
works best for you and I found that
that's really helped me to check my
phone less which is a lot less wasted
time on the phone and it's just like I
noticed that like I feel like I'm using
my muscles more like when I do those
exercises again may feel a little sore
and this is something that I just
started doing but I'm really pumped to
like see how it goes
hey Ryan this is Corbin from Austin
Texas and I wanted to share how you guys
have inspired me to stop asking what do
you do types of questions and ask more
what are you passionate about kinds of
question
as a college student the number one
thing you're asked and are asked when
meeting something new is what's your
major and through my experience this is
often a question to compare yourself
with whom you're talking to the liberal
arts major shy away from the question
and all business majors and engineering
majors often can't wait to tell you what
they study so what I've learned from all
this though I said it doesn't really
matter most of the time and most people
end up and careers are completely
different from what we studied in
college and like you guys that says the
better thing to ask is what are you
passionate about because this is much
less as a comparing kind of question
because people more excited to talk
about what they love and this leads you
to better understand them as a whole
person than just their title or their
debris that they got all right folks
that's it for today and and that is it
for a while at this point we will we'll
see you on the flip side whenever that
is and if you walk away from this with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got hey you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so tear your eyes or two